[Music]
welcome back to harvard unboxed today
we're taking a look at the new
radeon rx 6700 xt from amd
as well as a few different models from
partners
now this cut down rdna 2 gpu
is said to be targeting the 480 us price
point
so we'll have to see how that goes and
of course amd has been claiming
significantly improved
supply so again we'll have to see how
that goes
when compared to the 520 millimeter
squared navi 21 die
navi 22 which the 6700 xt is based upon
is considerably smaller at just 336
millimeters squared
that's a 35 reduction in die size and of
course both are manufactured
using tsmc's seven nanometer process
when compared to the 580 us rx 6800
and yes i'm going to compare the msrp
the 6700xt
is suggested to be just 17 more
affordable
which honestly really isn't that much
particularly given that it packs 33
percent fewer cores
tmus and rops moreover the memory
subsystem has also been downgraded
as the 192-bit wide bus offers a peak
bandwidth of 384 gigabytes per second
a 25 reduction when compared to the 6800
the smaller bus has also reduced the
memory capacity from 16 gigabytes to 12
gigabytes which really is a non-issue as
this product is targeting the 1440p
resolution and here an 8 gigabyte buffer
is still sufficient so that being the
case 12 gigabytes is more than enough
but so far we're looking at a rather
substantial 33 downgrade for the core
configuration and
25 percent less bandwidth all for just a
cost saving thankfully though the 6700
xt
does have one advantage and that comes
through clock speed as the cores are
clocked 23 percent higher
so while there are 33 percent less of
them they should be around
20 faster i should also note just
quickly that the infinity cache size has
been reduced by 33
as well from 128 megabytes with the 6800
to 96 megabytes for the 6700 xt
amd claims that this optimized on die
cash delivers up to two and a half times
the bandwidth of a 256 bit wide bus
running at 12 gigabits per second gddr6
memory
and just lastly when compared to the
6800 we're looking at just an 8
reduction in total board power which
makes sense given the cores are clocked
so much higher
so that's really a quick and rough look
at the 6700 xt specs and how they
compare to the next
product and the stack obviously with a
usmsrp the 6700xt is targeting the rtx
3070 from nvidia
and amd has claimed via their own
benchmarks
that this new gpu is typically faster
than the rtx 3070
of course using their own cherry-picked
range of games and
test conditions they did throw in watch
dogs legion to make their claim appear a
bit more legitimate but
most of the tiles were sponsored by amd
and are known to perform very well on
their hardware
also worth noting is the fact that amd
tested with smart access memory enabled
their branding for the pcie feature
called resizable bar
when testing across 35 games at 1440p we
here at harbour unboxed found that sam
boosted performance by three percent on
average
though we did see gains of 10 or more
and half a dozen of the titles tested
that said sam did also negatively impact
performance by a three percent or
greater margin
in five of the games now by default
we don't yet test with sam or resizable
bar
enabled for two reasons firstly it's not
supported on all platforms
so depending on your motherboard the
option may not be supported
and at this point amd is still only
offering support on
500 series boards when using a 5000
series processor
or a select 3000 series processor
and the second reason being that even if
you have the required hardware
the feature is not actually enabled by
default meaning the user needs to enter
the bios
find the resizable bar option and
manually enable it
this isn't that different to what we do
with say xmp
but it's another step we'd be making
only to enhance the performance of radio
and gpus
so for now at least we're not going to
do that though please note we will
provide some sam enabled results
showing where it works well and where it
doesn't
now for testing i'm still using my ryzen
9 3950x test system and i am still in
the process of updating to the 5950x
and you can expect all that data once we
get through the latest round of product
releases
the system is configured with 32
gigabytes of dual rank dual channel
ddr4 3200 cl 14 memory and finally i
will be focusing on the 1440p
data for almost a dozen of the 14 games
tested
and then we'll jump into the usual
performance breakdown graphs which will
include a look at the
1080p results as well and please note
that all graphs and data
will be made available to float plane
and patra members
okay let's get into the results first up
we have the watchdogs lesion data and
here the 6700 xt was 11
slower than the rtx 3070 and just two
percent faster than the rtx 3060 ti
so in other words we're looking at 360
ti performance in this title which
really doesn't bode that well for amd
given the 6700 xt
costs 18 more that said it is only 14
slower than the rx 6800 and that is a
great result for the 6700 xt and it
means we could be looking at very
impressive performance in amd optimized
titles
such as assassin's creed valhalla and
speaking of which
as expected in assassin's creed valhalla
performance is very impressive hitting
73 fps on average at 1440p
using the highest quality preset and
that made it just 10
slower than the rx 6800 and 14 faster
than the rtx 3070
so that really is a great result for amd
though i couldn't help but notice the
6700 xt was just 24
faster than the 5700 xt and while that's
certainly a decent performance
uplift remember it's almost coming in at
a
20 premium at least when comparing the
msrp
so that's hardly progress worth getting
excited about
the 6700 xt also performed well in death
stranding edging out the rtx 3070 by a
slim 4
margin so basically identical
performance between the two competing
gpus here
quite surprisingly the 6700 xt was just
slot in 6800 we are likely running into
a slight cpu bottleneck here with the
3950x which
will be resolved with the updated 5950x
test system
but i don't expect this margin to grow
beyond a few percent
then moving on to microsoft flight
simulator 2020 we find that the 6700 xt
isn't all that impressive here trailing
the 6800 by a 21
margin as it dropped down from 48 fps to
just 38 fps
that meant it was also 14 slow on the
rtx 3070
and even 5 slower than the 360 ti
perhaps even more disappointing was the
fact that it was just 19
faster than the 5700 xt
performance in shadow of the tomb raider
was also very disappointing
here the 6700 xt was only able to match
the cheaper rtx 3060 ti
making it nine percent slow on the rtx
3070 and
19 slower than the 6800 that said it did
offer an almost 30
performance uplift from the old 50 700
xt
the 6700 xt also struggles to keep pace
with the rtx 3070 and tom clancy's
rainbow six siege
this time it was 10 slower and again was
more comparable with the 3060 ti beating
it by a mere two and a half percent
margin
then when compared to the rx 6800 we're
looking at a 19
performance loss and when compared to
the 5700 xt
a 28 performance gain like assassin's
creed valhalla
godfall is an amd sponsored title and
it's well optimized for radeon gpus
as a result the 6700 xt blew away the
rtx 3070 offering 17
greater performance at least when
comparing the average frame rate the one
percent low performance was actually
very similar
quite interestingly the 6700 xt mimicked
the performance of the rx 6800 in this
title
and after multiple re-tests i received
pretty much the same results
please note that i did go back and
retest the 5700 series of gpus here and
found that performance had improved
since my previous testing quite a few
months ago now
the 5700 xt is now on par with the rtx
3060 ti and that meant
that the 6700 xt was 35 faster which is
still a much larger performance uplift
than what we've seen in other titles
now here's a look at performance in an
nvidia sponsored title wolfenstein
youngblood
as you'd probably expect the 6700 xt
doesn't have its best showing here
losing to the rtx 3070 by a 16 margin
and even the 360 ti by a six percent
margin
it was also 23 slower than the 6800
though it was 34
faster than the 5700 xt so pretty good
result there relative to the older
radeon part the f1 2020 results are
quite
disappointing really especially given
how the other radeon gpus perform
relative to their competing parts
for example the 6900 xt can be seen
beating the rtx 3090 the 6800 xt beat
the rtx 3080
and the 5700 xt easily beat the rtx 2060
super
the 6700 xt on the other hand that was
percent slow in the rtx 3070 and while
that is a fairly insignificant margin
again when compared to how the other
radeon gpus performed i did find this
quite disappointing
it also meant while it was just 16
slower than the 6800
it was also just 13 faster than the 5700
xt
last up here's a look at the horizon
zero dawn results and as you can see the
6700 xt finds itself positioned squarely
between the rtx 3070
and 3060 ti but they're all so close
here that it really doesn't matter so
let's call this one a tie
the 6700xt was just 11 slower than the
and 33 faster than the 5700 xt so when
compared to the other radeon products
that is a decent result okay so here's a
look at the 1080p data averaged across
our 14 game sample
at this entry level resolution the 6700
xt
averaged an average of 150 fps and that
meant it was
three percent slower than the rtx 3070
had we enabled sam for what would
probably be a three percent boost
performance would be identical though
you could get a similar overall boost
from enabling dlss 2.0 in the games that
support it
when compared to the cheaper rtx 3060 ti
we're looking at just a six percent
performance boost
and then just a 23 increase over the
5700 xt
while it was just 12 percent slower the
rx 6800
though again it notes some cpu
limitations will be present in this low
resolution data
then jumping to 1440p we find the 6700
xt was just four percent slow on the rtx
3070 and just six percent faster than
the rtx 3060 ti
this time it was 16 percent slow on the
rx 6800 and a much more impressive 30
faster than the 5700 xt though again it
also
costs 20 more so a pretty uninspiring
improvement there really
as we just saw when compared to the rtx
3070 the 6700 xt was on average four
percent slower at 1440p
and here's a look at how they compared
across the games tested godfall and
assassin's creed valhalla were the only
two big wins for amd
and if we remove those titles the 6700
xt becomes 7
slower then if we remove the two most
favorable games for nvidia the 6700 xt
is still six percent slower overall
so i can't see the new radio and gpu
coming out on top when testing a dozen
games or more
when compared to the rx 6800 the 6700 xt
was 15
at 1440p and if we remove the godfall
result it only drops a percent making it
slower so when compared to the 6800 it
does reasonably well
though it's only about 17 cheaper so
they're going to come in very similar in
terms of cost per
frame again when compared to the 5700 xt
the 6700 xt is rather uninspiring
sure it is 28 faster but it also costs
more so a very small generational
improvement
in terms of value now for a look at the
cost per frame and obviously this time i
can't include the ebay pricing data as
we did in the rtx 3060 review
as this content isn't being published
two weeks after release
no doubt tim and myself will revisit
this discussion later in the month in
our q a series
but for now here's the msrp comparison
as that really is the only meaningful
comparison that we can make
in terms of value the 6700 xt is a very
very small improvement over the rx 6800
we're talking about a two percent
discount per frame
that's not great and it means the rtx
3070 and in particular the rtx 3060 ti
are better value you're looking at a 14
discount per frame with the rtx 3060 ti
for example
and that's not good given they do
essentially occupy the same performance
tier
perhaps though the most disappointing
comparison that can be made is with the
5700 xt
here we're looking at just a seven
percent improvement in cost per frame
and yeah times have changed but after
two years i still find that
very disappointing if it were priced at
the 6700 xt would be a 23 improvement in
cost per frame and i think that would
have been a pretty amazing result
though it's also extremely wishful of me
given the current climate
and i suspect most of you would be over
the moon by the prospect of landing a
6700 xt for even
500 u.s now before wrapping up the
benchmark graphs we still have to take a
quick look at ray tracing performance
along with power consumption and
overclocking and of course i will have a
look at these aib models
see how they compare in terms of clock
speeds thermals
all that stuff we normally look at for
testing ray tracing performance we still
have to rely on nvidia sponsored titles
so it's hard to say exactly how well our
dna 2 performs
with ray tracing enabled given these
games aren't optimized for amd's
implementation
but it does prove the point that if you
want to enjoy ray tracing today
you're best off with an nvidia gpu
especially as performance can be boosted
by using technology such as dlss and
here we're seeing that using the medium
quality
rtfx the 6700 xt averaged just 36 fps
down from 84 fps without rt enabled
this is the same level of rt performance
you'll receive from an rtx 3060 in this
title
at least without the aid of dlss
enabling dlss boosted the 3060s
performance by 50
and therefore made it 50 faster than the
6700 xt
and of course we're only talking about
the rtx 3060 here the real competitor
is the rtx 3070 in this title it's 47
faster without the help of dlss and then
faster with dlss so that's not good and
as i've said countless times before
if you care about ray tracing
performance right now you'll want
a geforce 30 series gpu
ray tracing performance in shadow of the
tomb raider is much better
though we're only using rt to enhance
shadows here so
it is rather pointless in our opinion
though that's our take on road tracing
in most games i suppose
anyway using the ultra quality settings
the 6700xt managed 64fps on average
and that meant it was 23 slower than the
rtx 3070 and 30
slower with dlss enabled
wrapping up the ray tracing testing we
have control which is of course another
nvidia sponsored title
and here the rtx 3070 destroys the
6700xt with rt enabled
for rasterization performance the 3070
is already
well out in front beating the 6700 xt by
a 22
margin and that figure ballooned out to
a 58
margin with rt set to high and then 178
percent with dlss enabled
moving on i'm not going to show too much
sam related testing
we've already provided an in-depth
benchmark covering this feature with the
rx 6800
and scaling won't be that different with
the 6700 xt
one of the best examples with the 6800
was seen in assassin's creed valhalla
and here with the 6700 xt we're looking
at a healthy 12
performance boost which allowed it to
match the rx 6800 without sam enabled
but also as we found previously sam
doesn't work in all games and again
assassin's creed valor hala should be
considered
as a best-case scenario what we're
seeing here in microsoft flight
simulator 2020 isn't that unusual as
most games will see
little to no performance improvement
using pcat to measure the power draw of
just the graphics card we find the 6700
xt is comparable to the rtx 3070
sucking down 221 watts basically the
same kind of power consumption you'd see
with an rtx 2070 super
it was also 12 less power than the 5700
xd which is impressive given performance
in this total was boosted by 30 percent
using the amd reference model i was able
to overclock the cause to 2.75 gigahertz
and this resulted in a very mild 6
performance increase
remember this model is already clocked
much higher than the 6800
so that does reduce the available oc
headroom
it also means the rtx 3070 will
typically extract a little more
performance when manually overclocked
so for some of you that can help boost
its value rating and the same would also
be true when comparing it to something
like the rx
6800 since i've ended up with half a
dozen aib models for this release we're
just going to look at the peak gpu
hotspot temperature
after half an hour of gameplay in an
enclosed atx case
the corsair obsidian 500d this is stock
out of the box performance as i didn't
have time before the noise normalized
testing
dialing in each card does take quite a
bit of time the highest clocking models
were the gigabyte gaming oc and xfx
speeds to merc
319 and of the two the xfx model was far
more impressive
operating its fans at just 1000 rpm for
a hot spot temperature
of just 85 degrees the gigabyte model
was 2 degrees cooler but you're looking
at almost twice the fan speed
which does increase the operating volume
quite drastically
the gaming oc should be a fair bit
cheaper though so it could still
represent pretty great value
the power color red devil and hellhound
models were extremely impressive
both ran the fans at just 1000 rpm for
sub 80 degree temperatures
the red devil did clock around 100
megahertz higher and that made it one of
the best models we tested
sapphire's nitro plus almost forgot it
had fans spinning them at just 800 rpm
after
30 minutes of load this model also
appears to sip power despite running the
cores at 2.5 gigahertz
the hotspot temp did creep up to 91
degrees though that's not bad given the
whisper quiet fan speed
then we have the msi gaming x and this
is one of the least impressive models i
have to say
and i suspect it would be comparable to
the gigabyte gaming oc under noise
normalized test conditions
it was quite a bit better than the amd
reference design though so
there is that so what to make of the
radio rx 6700 xt
then it is really a bit too hard to make
a concrete conclusion because i don't
know what pricing and availability will
look like
i would guess not particularly good but
again amd has been claiming
significantly better availability than
navi 21 but of course that could just
mean they've got a few dozen cards ready
to sell
in all seriousness though i have reached
out to a few retailers
and it does sound like they've got a
decent amount of these things
certainly not enough to supply everybody
upon release
but you know that was never going to be
the case so we still expect them to sell
out
very quickly but they're at least
starting with a much more
healthy number than they have with
previous uh releases so
at least that's based on what i'm
hearing so availability should indeed be
better
assuming that the healthy numbers that
we're meant to be seeing upon release
keep getting updated refreshed we see a
we see cards flowing in on a regular
basis over the coming weeks and months
then it should make it a bit easier
to buy a 6700 xt but again all of that
remains to be seen
as for pricing well again that also
difficult to comment on that before they
go on sale but
here in australia i am hearing that it
sounds like these aib cards at least the
more
entry-level aib cards should be around
20 cheaper
than what aussies are faced with having
to pay for an rtx 3070
so that's pretty good availability
inflated prices aside for a moment let's
just assume we're living in
more normal times so the 6700 xt will
hit shelves today
quickly sell at the msrp and then supply
should catch up a few weeks down the
track
at which point you could easily buy one
for the 480 us msrp
or whatever the equivalent price is in
your region plus any taxes in block
costs and so on
in that reality the 6700 xt is a pretty
lukewarm product
it's a very very small improvement from
its predecessor in terms of value
yeah you do get a bit more vrm and
efficiency has been greatly improved
but overall a 30 performance increase at
a 20
price premium is hardly cause for
celebration
it's roughly equal to the rtx 3070 in
terms of value though
so it's hardly poor value relative to
the competition
but as we've discussed in the past it's
really not good enough for amd to just
price match nvidia in terms of cost per
frame
as there's more to the value equation
for example the radeon gpus lack the
same level of ray tracing maturity
we're still waiting on a dlss competitor
which is becoming more and more of a big
deal
as the game support list for dlss
continues to grow
albeit slowly but it is growing also for
streamers the nvidia encoder is still
much better so even if we accept that
gpus released in 2021 won't necessarily
stack up as well as we'd like them to in
terms of value compared to models
released in previous years due to
factors such as
the trade war resulting in stuff like
tariffs increased shipping costs and
of course increased manufacturing costs
all of which result in the products
being more expensive than they were just
a few years ago
it's still hard to accept the 6700 xt at
us given the missing features mentioned
a moment ago i feel the 6700 xt needs to
be at the very least 50
u.s less than the rtx 3070
of course as i discussed in our rtx 3060
review the reality of the situation is
that it makes a little sense for either
amd or nvidia to release a good value
gpu right now
both are selling absolutely everything
they can produce and therefore the
incentive for
amd to heavily undercut nvidia by a
meaningful margin
it's just not there they're not going to
gain any extra sales by doing so
so they'd really just be robbing
themselves of profit and that means
they've basically just price matched the
rtx 3070
sure it is 20 cheaper according to the
msrp
and you do get four gigabytes more vram
but you're still missing out on cutting
edge features like dlss
so if i had my choice of an rtx 3070
for 500 us that'd be nice or a 6700 xt
for 480
us i really do think i would go with the
geforce gpu a four percent discount just
really isn't enough for me to part with
features like dlss
especially given that i play games like
fortnite that support dlss
please don't judge me as for the six aib
models that i have on hand
they all worked very well my personal
favorites were the power color red devil
and xfx speeds to merc 319
though i suspect they will both be
rather pricey especially the xfx model
the power color hellhound was also
excellent and if they can deliver that
near the msrp once things return to
normal
then that will be one to look out for
the sapphire nitro plus is too quiet for
its own quit in my opinion and i suspect
it will perform very well
relative to the power color and xfx
models once noise normalized
though again i don't expect it to be
cheap the gigabyte gaming oc should be
good value and while the cooling
performance wasn't amazing given the
high fan speed
it certainly was acceptable the msi
gaming x is expected to be a premium
model there will no doubt be a ventus or
something cheaper
so i assume this is going up against the
likes of sapphire's nitro plus
xfx's merc and power colors red devil
and i hate to say it
but the gaming x just doesn't seem to be
in quite the same league
that said the performance was perfectly
acceptable so if the price is right this
will be another model to look out for
and that is going to do it for this
review of amd's new radeon rx
6700 xt let me know what you think
about the 6700xts in the comments
section below what do you make of this
new
offering uh we'll be sure to read all of
your comments because yeah i'm very
interested to see what you guys make of
this thing
and i guess your comments and opinions
will probably be shaped by what
availability looks like but again it's
probably going to take a few weeks
before we know
exactly well we're going to know if this
is any any better
than what we we've seen so far and yeah
i
don't have high hopes on that but amd
say significantly more supply and they
seem very optimistic but
we know what happened last time amd was
very optimistic about their supply for
gpus anyway it won't say any more we'll
leave it at that
if you'd like to get more involved with
the hardware box channel you can support
us over at floatplane or patreon that
will get you access to stuff like
behind the scenes content q and a's live
streams with two of myself which we do
at least one of those per month
uh what else have we got we've got an
exclusive discord chat so you can jump
over there
really awesome community that loves
talking about pc hardware and
all that kind of stuff so yeah if you're
interested check it out if not perfectly
fine
i would like to thank you for watching
this video i'm your host steve and i'll
see you
again next time
[Music]
you